よろしくお願いします
今日の あまり深い仏教の中身には入りませんけど
何回も繰り返しているテーマでもありますけどね
でもこの宣伝文句を読むと
なんかどうまとめればいいかっていう
ちょっと疑問もできますけどね
いろんなところを喋りすぎて
一応あの 焦点を当てようとしているのは
この物事を変えるべきか ないか
変えられるか ないか というところなんですね
それが必要だと 昔の人が思っていたことを証明するために
キリスト教のお祈り文句を入れてるんですけど
ですから その祈り文句の中の意味も
やっぱりこの 個人が物事を変えたいんですね
でも勇気がない それから何を変えた方がいいか
何を変えてはいけないかということの 識別もない状態を泣いてるんですね
で 祈りっていうのは
仏教から言えば やっぱり希望を言ってることで
ちょっと悪口と言えば 泣いてるんですけどね
この希望を語る言葉っていうのは
どんな人間にもすぐ感動的で インパクト強く心に響くんですよ
どんな宗教でもこの祈り文句っていうのは 大変 感動的だと思ってるんですね
ヒンドゥー教でもTamaso Ma Jyotirgamayaとかね
大変有名な文句で みんなすごく大事に 愛情を持って覚えている言葉なんですね
暗闇から光へ(我を)導きたまえ という意味なんですね
ヒンドゥー教も 同じく知恵っていうものが必要だと言ってるんですからね
それ仏教の智慧とは違いますけどね
その場合も 自分で地を切り拓くんじゃなくて
光へ導きたまえと なんかすごくかっこよさそうに聞こえるんですけどね
だから待ってるんですよ
誰か引っ張ってくれるまで
押してくれるまで
それは一つ 人間の弱みでね
誰かが尻を叩いて 動かさないと動かない
そのまんまでいる それはどんな人間にも大体はあることで
ですから 他に頼ると祈りということがね
一応 なかなか社会から離れなくなっちゃいますね
で 人間の本来の弱みですから
でお釈迦様もやっぱり 人を後ろから激しく叩いてるんですよ
歩けと 動けと で その場合はこの祈りとは違うんですね
ものすごい具体的で 現実的に
心を叩いちゃうんですね
いわゆる 心立てるのではなくて
一応 現実的に 人々を戒めているんですね
それから物事を変えるべきかというポイントについて 考えてみましょう
私たちが生きてるこの現代世界では
激しく物事が変わっていくんですね
それでだいたい 年取っている人々以外はね
みんな物事をもう激しく
もう 変えたくて 変えたくて
もう大変いら立っているというかね
落ち着いてないんですね
とにかく変えようと　それから若い人々の間では
変えたということ
新しいと 流行だと そういう言葉も 大変かっこいい言葉になっているんですね
ですから もうあなたちょっと古いんじゃないかなという一言は
もうちょっと人をバカにして言ってる言葉なんですね
もう古すぎだと という一言だけでも
ですから この世の中ではみんな 変わること
何か新しくすること 大変かっこいいんだと
そう思っているんです
だから 変えるべきかということは
それで 問題にはなりますね
なぜかというと この現代
我々の世界では とにかく変えればいいんですよ
ただそれだけで それだけちょっと理解しておけば
もうかなり現代的で流行に乗っているというか
流行を先取りしている人になるんですよ
もう何でもいいんです
あるものはちょっと変える
それだけ　それで変えてからは
良くなろうが悪くなろうが
それは関係ないんです
ただ変えれば それが流行なんですね
今 思い出すのは かなりもう
今から見れば 私にとってかなり前なんですけど
このイギリスでなんか流行があったんで
みんな頭は両側剃っちゃうんですね
剃って前なんか ニワトリの頭の上にあるもののように 伸ばしておいて
これまた 真っ赤な色で染めて染めちゃうんですね
真っ赤とか青とかね 緑とか
で 両側がもう全部剃るんです
随分それ流行ったんですけど
日本でも 若い人々はそれやっていましたしね
それでまたそれ変わったんですね
だからそれでいいかどうか
そうではなくて ただ変えればいいということだけなんですね
服のことを見ても
とにかく変えればいいんです
それでいろいろこの ファッションショーというんでしょうかね
ありますね テレビで放映してますから
見てください あんなものを着て人の前に出られますかね
時々何かこの 大きなザルを被ったようなスカートもあるし
何かビニール袋に入って ビニールで作った服のようなものもあるし
お尻なんかほとんど外へ出して歩く 見えるように丸出しの服のデザインもあるし
それまた世界一流のデザイナーだそうですね
で 億万長者だけにね 結局はみんな変えればいいという思考でいるんですよ
悲しいことは それにもみんなすごく苦労しているんですね
だから変える場合 例えばこちら
水がありますね ペットボトル
これをこうやって 普通だったらもう横に立っておくのは常識ですけどね
これをただこうやってしておけば
それ変えただけなんですね
それは流行ってるんだぞと
別に考える必要ないんですよ
それでまたもう 2 3ヶ月とかになっちゃうと
これまたつまらなくなったら
こうやって蓋を下にして立てるようにすれば
もう変えてるんですね
でもそれでもちょっとやばいぞと
倒れそうだったらまた何か発明するんですね
この倒れないようにすると
またそれは面白く面白くないと思っちゃったら
またもうこういう風にするようにします
変えるっていうことは そんなもんなんですけどね
それほど 大したことではありません
今 ご飯を食べる場合は
デザートは最後に食べますけどね
もっと流行というと デザート先に食べても何が悪いんですか？
それも変えることなんですよ　それはなんとか流とか言ってね
で 何か新しい名前でもつけて
もうデザートを先に食べると
それから逆順番で食べるんだよと言えば
それも変えることで
例えば 日本でお箸でご飯召し上がりますけど
なんでお箸とフォークだけ使うようにしないんですか？
だからフォークだったらナイフつなげますけど
もうそれでフォークとナイフでなければあかん
そうじゃなくて なんでフォークとお箸で食べて悪いんですかね
それも変えることだから
だから そういうなんか自信ないでしょうね
変えるためには そういう風な変え方には
だからこの変えることは流行だとね
すごいもう飛んでる人々だと ものすごい現代的と言うんだけど
結局は 片っ端から何でも変える自信はないんです
まだ怯えているんです
なんでそんな情けないかと 思いたいんだけどね
だからこの世の中の人々は とにかくものを変えるんだけど
それでいろいろ 心の中で葛藤があったり
もういろんなことを考えたりして
うまく変えることさえできないんですね
それでいろんな苦労して
もう精神的に ボロボロ状態になるまで苦労して
考えて なんとかちょっとわずかに変えると
別に誰もそれ変えたことに 何も文句を言うわけじゃないんですけど
だから私が言いたいのは
変えるということは いとも簡単なことなんですけど
なんでそんな苦労するんですかと
だって今まで変えて 世界を変えてきたものにしても
別に人間に人類について 良い結果出しましょうと思って 変えたわけじゃないでしょう
とにかく何かする それだけのことでしたから
ほとんど ひどい結果になってしまったでしょうに
いろんな病気が出てくるわ
自然を破壊するわ 体はおかしくなるわね
そういうことになってるんだから
ただみんな変えればいいという話で生きているんですね
だったら いとも簡単に 変えてしまえばいいんですけど
それはできないところは何でしょうかと
それが一つ 大変 大事な問題なんですよ
いくら人間がやっぱり流行だ
新しいデザインだ 新しいファッションだ
新しい食べ物だとかね
と 何て言いますか 自慢したいんだけど
どこかで心の中でものすごい
重い思いを持ってるんです
なかなか動かないんです
結局 私に言えるのは この流行に走って飛んでいて
これが現代的だという人々も 徹底的な保守主義で
すごく古臭い考え方に
縛りつけられているんだということなんです
正直じゃないんです だからこの
我々古い人間がね
古くてね 何も変えることは もう好きじゃないなと
もうすごく悪口 言われるでしょうしね
それはそれでいいんですよ
もう別に もう変えなくたってもいいんですからね
放っておいてくださいと
年取ってる人のことは
では 若い層の方々は それほど自由に
生きてるかというと 我々より不自由なんですよ
思考は不自由 生き方は不自由
いろんな概念 いろんな思考概念
固定概念 いろんな決まり
自分で作っては作っては
それに束縛されちゃって自由がないんです
そこが考えてほしいポイントなんですよ
変えればいいというならば
私が言うのは 変えると それだったら
そんな難しくないんだと
もうとっくに形できてるんだから
それを変えるだけだから
それに何の創造性も インスピレーションも要りません
何かインスピレーション 必要ですかね
このペットボトルを横に倒しておくことには
何もいらんでしょうに
もうすでに形決まってるんだから
立たせておくという
ですから 変えることは難しいということは
ズボンはね 頭から履くことはちょっと無理ですけどね
シャツはもう足から
もう穿けてみるとかね
だからズボンは上とシャツは下
そこまで変えることは ちょっと構造上 無理ですけど
ほんのちょっと考えれば それもできますよ
また切ってちょっと縫い直せばできるんだから
だから自分の国で この自分が学生の時はね
時々 人をからかう時はね
いい加減なことを言ったりすると
一つ ことわざみたいなものを我々 作ったものを言うんですよ
あなたのズボンを頭から脱がしてやり
脱がしてやるぞと それは無理だからね
そんなこと言うと ズボンは頭から脱がしてやるぞと
だからズボンは下へ脱ぐんであっても
頭からは無理ですからね
だから その言葉にしても
やっぱり もう変えることを考えて言ってるんです
で 私が言うのは それはなんで実行できないですかね
頑張れば実行できます
ズボンもシャツと同じく 上から脱ぐように作ればいいんだから
簡単でしょうに 下にジップでもつけておけば
それだけでね 脱げますよ
ですから 変えるということは
そんなに大した大変なこと ということではないんです
我々老人の人々は それにびっくりする必要も
悩む必要も何もないんですよ
どんなアホな人にもできることなんですね
だから それは問題ないんだけど
問題がなんでそんなに変えることには すごい苦労しているんですかと
ほんのわずかでも 何か世界にあることを変えるためには
もう苦労という 並ならぬ苦労
なんでしょうかね それが
言ってはいけない例なんですけど
このテーラワーダ協会の組織やら いろいろね
新しい活動やら どうしようかというと
私はもう大胆な意見を言いますよ
それの一方的な意見は良くないんだからね
じゃあみんなの意見はいかがでしょうかと
一応 聞くんだけど
ろくな意見は言ってくれない ということを知ってるんです
なぜかというと 新しく物事を考えることは ものすごい難しいんですよ
心には どこかでこの巨大な山に ものすごい鎖で
足の先から頭のてっぺんまで 縛りつけてるような感じなんですよ
その中で ちょっと指ぐらい変わってるんですよ
人間の生き方っていうのは
そうやって大きな ものすごい強い柱にもずっと鎖で縛ってるんですね
そこでちょっとまぶたぐらい閉じるとかね
ちょっと指ぐらい ちょっと動かせるぐらいね
変えるのはそんなもんなんですよ
だからそういう風に 何か意見を言ってくださいと言ったら
あのもう古い もう日本の仏教の習慣とかね
なんとか ある大乗仏教の 何かの宗派の考え方とか持ってきて
こういう風にやるんではないか
なんであなた方はそうするんでしょうかと
話にならんでしょうね
そんなことは 古い方法に変えたとしても
だから 古い伝統的な教えで
なかなか現代時代に意味がないんだから
私はブッダの教えを教えているんであって
ブッダが教えてなかった教え
いろんな人々が 好き勝手に喋ったものは どうせ古臭いんですよ
時代は後かもしれません
お釈迦様が亡くなって 600年経ってから 人々が作った教えかもしれませんけど
もう普通の人間が書いた経典だから
もう古臭いんです
ブッダの教えとは桁違うんです
だからそれは世界で古くなっちゃって
有効期限がなくなっちゃうんですね
賞味期限が消えているんです
それで賞味期限が もうとっくに消えている
もう 400年も消えてるんですから
じゃあ 賞味期限は切れない話をしようではないかと
するとまた あれを持ってくるという
やっぱりそこで何が理解できるかというと
我々にとっては 変えるということは 大変難しくなっているんですね
そこで仏教の歴史から見ると
お釈迦様が 当時にあった思考体系
それから習慣 全部変えちゃったんです
人間に想像できないほど変えてしまったんです
それはほとんどの人々には理解できなかったんですね
あまりにもこの変化が あまりにも早すぎて
もう流行に乗ることができなかったんですね
そこで その仏教という流行に乗り遅れた人々が
もう師匠はわからない
生き方がわからない それで自分たちでまた新しい思想を書くんですよ
作るんですね　作って 我々はこういう風にやるんだぞと
お釈迦様は比丘たちに 出家者たちに 新しい生き方を教えたんですね
それが無理な人々が 古い方法へ帰りますと
言って もう何も 戒律も 生き方も 守らないことは素晴らしいことだと
一般の人々と ごちゃ混ぜになって
もうみんなと欲に溺れて生活すること
これこそ菩薩行だと 結局 何をしたんですかね
お釈迦様が 新しい生き方を教えたのに
元に戻っただけなんです
例えば 一般的に言えば
戒律という生き方を設定したのに
それは捨てて 何もない
いい加減な 欲に溺れて生活する生き方をまた
葬られているものを また掘り返して持って来る
教えとしても誰にも頼るなかれと
騙されちゃいますよ　自分には自分しかないんだぞと
自分のことを一番心配するのは自分でしょうと
だったら自分の面倒は自分で見なさい
という教えが ものすごい最新型の教えなんですよ
それは今も この世の中で機能していないんです
今になっても
今の現代人も この 21世紀の この IT 時代の
といって 自分のことを威張っているでしょうに
私は批判的に言うんですけど
この 21世紀の IT 時代の人々も
結局は 他に頼ることが生き方だと思っているでしょう
中国に あるアメリカのスパイ飛行機が 着陸したっていうんですね 緊急着陸
それで 24人の人々は後々アメリカに戻ったら
BBC とか またアメリカのテレビ放送局ですね
BBC はイギリスですけど
全部そちらで見ましたけどね
その人々をインタビューするんですね
もうかなり何か 言うことからね
全部もう 厳しく叩き込まれているな ということは見えたんだけどね
普通のアメリカ人の若者の明るさも
いい加減さも ふざけてしゃべることも何もない
だからこういう風に聞いたらこういう風に答えろと
叩き込まれたと思いますけどね
ですから このアメリカの方が一般のね
人々に感情を引き起こすために 何か言ってほしいんですね
だから自分たちがもうこの世の中でないほど 精神的にいじめられたとかね
拷問されたとかね やっと命拾いしたというような感じであった方が
あのもう単純なアメリカの人々には 理解しやすいんですよ
では あんまり現代そんなことは起きませんからね
もうただ そこまでだけでね
普通にいただけで 電子メールを送ったりとか
アメリカの家族に手紙を出したりとかね
毎日 コンタクト取ったりしていたんだからね
それで あなたはその時は どういう精神状態でしたかと
何を考えたんですか？と言ったら
年下の若い人がこう言うんですね
やっぱり家族っていうのは いかにありがたいかと思ったんですかと
それから人っていうのは神様を信じるべきですよと
神様を信じることは いかに大事かと思いますかと
という答えなんです だから私は
これであなた 現代人 世界の若者かと
これで最新型の軍事飛行機なんか操って
人のスパイ活動をする
もう一番最新 に走っている人ですか？と
ただの田舎のもう一人のアホではないかと
と自分が勝手に思っただけで
誰にも聞こえなかったんですけど
どうしてもロジクス成り立たないんですね
なんで神様を信じることは 大変ありがたいとわかるんですかね
逆に神様は全く信じない中国人が 着陸許可したことで命を助けたんですけど
着陸拒否したらどうなるんですかね
どうなるんでしょうかね
終わりでしょうに　だから論理的に考えれば
これはどんな国が悪いか
それは私たちに関係ないことだから
ただ このちょっとした最近のニュースだからね
私はただ論理的に考えるだけ
もし中国が厳しい共産圏だからね
もう着陸拒否と 入ったら撃つぞ と言ったら
海に行かなくちゃあかんでしょうに
行って着陸の代わりに墜落いたしますと
あるいは 中国人が着陸許可したのは
もう神様に脅されたんだからと
神様に脅迫されちゃって
我々は怯えて 一応着陸は許可しましたと
一人でも言ったならば
やっぱり神様を信じることは 大変ありがたいと
と言ってもいいんだけど
そういう証拠は何もなくて
ふざけて考えちゃうと
着陸許可したんだから
中国も飛行機は まだ返してないしね
今も そのままあるみたいですけど
そんなもんだと思いますけどね
ですから 人間っていうのは不思議なもので
あの今になっても お釈迦様みたいな
この大胆なことを言う話は 理解さえもできないんですよ
理解さえもできない 自分に頼ると
だからずっとこの 原始時代から 猿人というかね
あの猿人というんですか
プリマーツ(Primates 霊長類)という あの猿が人間に成りかかっている
その時からも 他人に頼って
木を拝んで 山を拝んで生きてきたんだからね
助けてくれと 病気治してくれと
今になっても変わってないんですよ 人格は
それで私が言いたいのは
仏教徒に向かって 仏教に向かってね
古いと言うなよと
もうかなりひどいことを言われるんだよ と言ったら
だから人間というのは
この物事を新しく変えるんだ
変えるんだと言っても
結局 何をなさっているんでしょうかね
何も変わってないんです 結局は
変わっているといえば
もう建物を作るとかね
工学的なね 発展がありますから
服のものもね 素材が変わるとか
それぐらいのことでしょうね
着るものは変わるとかね
乗り物が変わるとか 人が変わらないんですよ
で そこは何でポイントにしたんでしょうかというと
この変わりたくない 変えたくないという
この頑固さ
その硬さが 生まれてからもあるんです
我々は柔らかくはないんです
柔軟性がないんです
とにかく本当のところが 変わることが嫌なんです
変わることを徹底的に嫌がっちゃうんです
嫌がって やっぱり世界を変えなくてはいけませんと また言う
それで生きていられますかね
心の中はもう ものすごい
ものすごいきつくて もう徹底的に頑固で硬くて
柔軟性が全くなくて でも口先で変えましょう 変えましょうと言う
それも 自分たちが口先で言ってるだけだと いうこともわからないんです
本心だと勘違いしている
この葛藤 この矛盾 この偽善を背負って
人類は幸せだと思いますかね
楽だと思いますかね
だからどちらかはっきりした方が すごく楽なんですよ
例えば おじいちゃん おばあさま方はもう頑固で
孫たちにあっち行けと
あなたの言うこと聞かんぞと
楽にいるんですよ 例えばおじいちゃんも心臓が弱いんだから
朝早く起きてもう走るなよと 言っても走る
いくら言っても　もう病気だから
もう血圧高いんだからね
こんな食べ物食べるなよと言ったら
ああそうですかと言って
家で食べさせないんだったら 外へ行って食べる
それでその人が生き方は楽なんですよ 別に
それで廃人になっても
楽に生きている だから頑固さが
でも正直で 私は頑固やと思ったら
あの葛藤が消えちゃうんですよ
心の中で むやむや状態がなくなっちゃうんです
しっかりするんですね
その分は楽なんですね
頑固さ 正しいということではないんだけど
で 一般の人々 大勢の人々っていうのは
だから今のおじいちゃん おばあさま方にも 頑固になれないんですよ
なりたくても　なぜかというと
もう最初から批判されているんだから
だから頭の悪い孫たち
言うことばっかり聞いて
それに合わせようとして 骨折れてしまうんです
ですから 頑固はいいわけじゃないんだけど
やっぱりそれでも葛藤がない方がいいんじゃないかなと
一般の世界は すべてのみんなは
やっぱりその ものすごい激しい
この矛盾といえば矛盾であって
偽善といえば偽善であって
そういう生き方をしているんですね
だから全く正直ではありませんね
それで我々には一歩一歩 歩むこと
人生を歩むことは 大変な苦労なんです
ヒマラヤの頂上のところで歩くことと 同じなんですよ
エベレストの上の方に行ったら
ほんのちょっとしかないんですけど 登るところは
でも 一歩でもものすごく大変なんです 登るのは
それぐらい私たちの生き方が苦しくなってるんですね
ですから それはどういうことかというと
口先でもう変えますよと
なんでも我々は現代人だよと
今は 21世紀ですよと
今は IT 時代ですよとか言いながら
結局は原始人には変わりはありません 人格はね
だからちょっ と面白おかしく想像してみてください
原始人 一人連れてきて
この世の中でちょっと楽な世界ですよ
この日本の社会は コンビニなんか 24時間やってますからね
森に入って獲物を取って 焼いて食べる必要ないんだよと言って
原始人 一人 この東京どこかにもう入れてみた
想像してください どうなるんでしょうかと
その人にとっては 森の中にいるよりも
もう危険しか何もない
食べるものっていうのは全くもない
大変苦しいんですよ だから我々も精神的に原始人で
この表面的なところで現代人で生きるということは
大変な苦しい生き方だと思います
それが仏教で言いたいポイントなんですよ
だから 残念なことに ブッダの話っていうのは 随分現代的なんです
だからみんな納得いかない
私に対していろいろ文句を言う
でも皆様が想像している 頭の中でイメージしているお坊さんとは違うんですね
実際のブッダの弟子たちが
もう別に みんなに優しい言葉をかけて慰めてあげて
おだててあげて いい格好をつけようということは ほとんどないと思いますけど
それはケースバイケースで やるかもしれません
だけど一般的にはあまりやらないですね
ですから こういう激しく喋るということは
この私だけの特色というよりも
仏典を読んでみると もうものすごい激しいんですよ
それはいくら日本訳しても 読まないことは大変ありがたい助け
救いになってます あるいは読んでも
自分の 今までの固定概念で読むんだから
頑固な心で読んでるんだから
心は変化しませんだからね
読んで落ちるんだからね
読んでみてください もう本当に
ちょっと意味を吟味して
かなり鋭く激しく言ってます
一つ例を言います お釈迦様はカースト制度を壊しちゃったんですね
そんなものはもう あまりにもおかしいんだと
人類っていうのは一緒だよと
ワンスピーシス(one species 一つの種)だよと
いわゆるこの犬がいて
猫がそれは 2種類ですよ
で 動物たちね  4つの脚で走る動物たちがいて
鳥たちがいて また蛇たちがいるとかね
そうやって いろいろカテゴリーがあるんだよと
でも 人間っていうのはカテゴリーは一つですよと
すごい科学的に言うんですよ
お釈迦様のそれの理由は
どんな人間を見ても
食べるもの同じで 生き方が同じで
子供 はっきりとそう言うんですよ
子供の育ち方同じです
産み方同じですと 成長の過程もみんな同じですと
ですから その小学生でね
動物のことを勉強すると
そこら辺でしょ どのように生まれるかと
幼虫の時代 どういうふうなものかと
成虫になったら どういうふうなことですかと
交尾はどういう風にするんですかと
これで寿命はどれぐらい
それでカテゴリーに入れちゃいますから
お釈迦様はそういう枠でカテゴリーに入れたら
人間というのは一つしかいません
だからあなた方は 全くアホなことを言っているんだと
嘘を語っているんだと
カースト制度で神様が 人間の区別を作ったんだぞと
そんな区別はないんだと
どう見ても 嘘を言うなよ という立場で語ったんだけど
それでもあるバラモンが お釈迦様に攻撃しちゃったんですね
あなたは不可触民族でハゲ頭で
あの よくも偉大なる神の子たるバラモン人たちをね
批判するんだ と言ったら
お釈迦様はすごく丁寧に答えたんだけど
お釈迦様の論点は あなた方バラモン人は犬より以下ですよと
こういう論理で言ったんですよ
お釈迦様はこう言うんです
私はすべてのバラモン人を批判しませんと
私はすごい道徳のある 行儀のいい
心を清らかにしている人々は
たとえバラモン人であろうが 何人であろうが批判しませんよと
それで私が知ってますよと
昔々のバラモン人たちが もう金儲かることは考えなかったんだと
お金を集めることはしなかったんだと
そこで昔の犬たちも 金儲けよう 金儲けようとしなかったんだと
でも今のあなた方は 朝から晩まで
人から金を奪って 金儲かることしか考えていないんだと
でも今の犬も 昔と同じく未だに金儲けしませんよと
だから今のバラモンたちは 犬よりは以下ですよと
それで昔のバラモンたちが すごく欲が少なくて
女性のところに行ったならば
それは子孫を作る目的だけで
欲に溺れようとではなくて
女の人をもう何とかしようということではなくて
やっぱり子孫を作っていかないとよくないんだという
大変 大事な仕事として
自分の同じ バラモン人の女の人を嫁にもらったんだと
それで子孫を作って それでも欲を捨てたんだと
昔の犬も同じで 交尾するのは子孫を作る時だけですよと
好き勝手に犬を追っかけていかないんだと
それで犬は メス犬としか一緒になりませんと
豚とかね 山羊とかね そういう動物を追っていかないんだと
でも今のバラモン人はどうですかと
好き勝手に もうカーストも何も気にしないで
気に入っている女の人を 奪って犯してるんではないかと
でも犬は未だにあの道徳を守っているんだよ
ですから あなた方の生き方は犬より以下ですよと
そういう風にも激しい批判ですよ
これは当時インドで この宗教家として拝まれてる人々に対して向かっても
あなた方よりは犬の方が素晴らしいですよ ということはね
いかにきつい言葉といえばね
だから お釈迦様も別に言いたいことはおっしゃいますからね
そういうポイント
ですから この 仏教というそのものが本当にすごい
新しく物事 変化することには
決して反対ではありません
逆に言うのは あなた方には何もできませんと
物事を新しく改良することは
だからあなた方は苦しんで悩んでいるんだよと
新しいアイディア 新しい真理と言ったら
あなた方はもうボケーっとして 何もわからなくなっちゃうんだよと
ただ古臭いものばっかり言うと
すごい気持ちよくなっちゃって 聞くだけでしょうと
だから仏教は攻撃するのは
この人にある 精神的な頑固さ
変えようとしない その心
その精神 その硬さを激しく批判しているんですね
柔軟になりなさいよと　その方が楽ですよ
頑固イコール もう頭が悪いということだからね
何も変えたくないということは
何も変化もないし 何も進展もないし 何も進歩もないし
頭が悪くなる
それで思い浮かんだ一つのエピソードがあるんです
これは長部経典にあるエピソードなんです
パーヤーシラージャンニャスッタ(Pāyāsi Rājañña Sutta)という名前の経典なんですけど
この おそらくその経典というか
この出来事起きたのは
起きた時はお釈迦様はいなかったと思います
あるお坊さんにパーヤーシという名前の
[Pāyāsī]
人なんですけど これラージャンニャ(rājañña)と書いていますけど
大王ではなくて 小さなどこか地方ですかね
治めていた 王みたいな人なんですね
だからラージャンニャっていうのはなかなか
ラージャは王と日本訳できますけど
ラージャンニャといえば 大王だったら小王と言わないね
日本語で 小王か小王と言わないんですね
だから日本訳はできない
小さな王という意味で ラージャンニャという言葉を使っています
あるいはプリンスという意味で訳してもよろしいしね
その人が このパーヤーシさんが
すごい明確な人で 厳密に唯物論者なんですよ
彼が考えているのは 人間の体っていうのは
世の中にある地水火風でできているんであって
それで死んじゃったら体が地水火風に戻る　それだけ
もし誰かが 人がね
道徳を守るんだぞとかね
悪いことをするんだぞとかね
道徳（的行為）をして天国に行くんだぞとかね
悪いことをして地獄に落ちるぞと言ったら
それほどアホな嘘が世の中にないんだよと
死んだらもう体が壊れる　それで終わり
というもう徹底しているんです
あるお坊さんがその国に行って
説法するんだと言ったら
そのお坊さんが 道徳の話とかね
言ってるんだから 話を聞いて
なんてアホな坊主ですかね
また来て人を騙そうとしてるんだと　自分の国民をね
行って一つ言ってあげるんだ と言って
もうこのお坊さんを追い出したくて
大体 唯物論者っていうのは 宗教はすごく嫌いだからね
でもインドではやっぱり嫌いだからといってね
いきなりこの何て言いますか
刑務所に入れたりとかね
殺したりとかね そういうふうなことはしないんですね
一応 理屈で論理的に攻撃して
あなたが言ってることは間違ってるんだから
出ていってください というふうな状態なんですね
それでこのパーヤーシさんが そのお坊さんに会って
あなた本当ですかね？人が死んじゃったら天国に行くんだとかね
あたなだけじゃなくて
この宗教家がみんな言ってるんだよと
私はみんなインチキ嘘つきだと思ってますよ
と言ったら お坊さんが何のことなく
そう言わないで やっぱりいいことをした方がいいと思いますよ
悪いことをした方がしたら悪いと思いますよ
そういうふうに考えた方がいいんじゃないかと
言ったら彼が彼の研究を言うんですよ
で 私はもういろいろ研究して言ってるんですと
一つは 人間が死んで 地獄でも天国でも行くんだったら
霊魂(が出て)行かなくてはいけないでしょうにと
それで私のところにこの犯罪者がよく捕まってくるんだと
それで私がこの犯罪者を死刑にするんだと
死刑にするとどうせ殺すんだから
霊魂が出ていくことはちゃんとチェックできるんだからね
ちゃんとチェックするんだと
ある日 私は血一滴もこぼさないように
人を殺しちゃったんだ
その時は 人を殺す前に ちゃんと測ってみたんだと 体重を
ちゃんと測って
血一滴も出ていかないようにして
その人は窒息させて殺しちゃったんだと
処刑に決めた人だからね
殺してからその遺体を測ってみたんだと
遺体を測ってみたら なんと生きている時よりも 死んだ時は重さ 重いんだ
生きていた時に測ったよりも ほんのわずか重くなったんであって 軽くなってない
それでもし魂があって
人が死んだところで 魂が出ていったならば
もう魂の重さがないでしょうに
もう軽くなったんじゃなくて 重くなったんだ
だからあなた方は嘘を言ってるんだと
そういう人殺したり もう一つ
釜に入れて 釜に蓋をつけてシールを貼って
空気も出ないように それで殺しちゃうんですね
殺してあの蓋をすぐ割る
割った瞬間で見ているんだそうです
この霊魂が出ていくかと
見えなかったんですね
やっぱりないと それで決めるんですね
そういういろいろ研究したみたいですね
それでこのお坊さんの送った返事は
ある人が私に 私はあなたに
もう一つ物語を言いますよと
ある人がこの大きなほら貝を見つけるんだと
見つけて そのほら貝を吹くんだと
吹くとものすごい響く声が出てくるんだと
それで一人の馬鹿者がいて
なんて素晴らしい音ですかと
響くんだと 体までこの音に
このほら貝からこの音が出たんだと
ですから その音を探してみようかなと思って
ほら貝を持ってきて 上から見るは下から見ると
中に目を入れてみるとか　でも見えません
この音 どこにあるんでしょうね
でも最終的には ほら貝を破ってみるんだと
破ってみても その人には音は見つからないんだと
あなたどう思いますか？と王様に聞くんですよ
その人はすごい研究者だと思いますか　と言ったら
その人は研究者ではなくてバカもんだよと
だってホラ貝の音っていうのは
人が自分で取って 適当に口を合わせて吹かないと 出てこないんだからね
ホラ貝の中の音はあるわけじゃないんだと
だから私も王様に言いたいんだけど
王様もそうやってね 人の魂を探しても同じことだと
王様にバカとは言ってないんです
それ 仏教のやり方 自分で言わせるんです
最初の例えを出して
もう一つ例 言うんですよ
私のこの親戚とかね いるんですよ
ものすごい悪い人々が
人は殺すは 女は奪うは
もうやりたい放題の悪いことをするんだと
それで私はしっかりと
このお坊さんたちの言うことは本当であるならば
この人々は地獄に落ちるんだと
ですから私は その親戚が死にかけていると行くんだよと お見舞いに
行ってこう言うんだと
あなたはね 生きている間はずっと悪いことをしたんだよ
だからあなたは この出家者の話によると
地獄に落ちるんだと ですから地獄に落ちたならば私に言ってくれ
やっぱりあれは本当でしたと
地獄に落ちたんだよと
言ってくれと言ったら
その人々もちゃんと約束するんだと
はい わかりましたと申し上げますと
約束して死ぬんだけど
一度でも言ってくれたことがないんだと
だからあなた方は嘘を言うんだよ　と言ったら
このお坊さんの反論がね
じゃああなたに聞きますけど
あなたのところにこの犯罪者が来たら
あなたはもう裁く 裁くと言うんですか
して まあ例えば10年刑とかね
20年刑とか何かに決める
あるいはもうすぐ処刑に決めると
打ち首にすると そうするとその犯罪者があなたにこう言うんだよと
王様 ちょっと待ってください
私の親戚がいて この親戚が私に忠告したんだよと
この泥棒をしたら 悪いことをしたら
あなたは殺されますよと
ですから もしそういうふうなことになったならば
私に言ってくれと そうすると私も泥棒しないで済みますよと
私は約束したんだから 私の親戚に
だから王様 ちょっと待ってください
私は 私の親戚に これから私は殺されますよと言ってきますから と言ったら
あなたはその犯罪者を逃がしてあげますかと
そうしたら とんでもないんだと
逃がすどころか もうその場で捕まえて
もう刑務所に入れて首を切るんだと
もう親戚に会わせませんと
誰とも もう犯罪者だからと
だったら地獄に落ちたら どうやってあなたに報告するために来られますかと
もう犯罪者だから地獄から解放してくれないんだと
あなたに それぐらいのことわからないんでしょうかと
それで 王様は負けた
負けたくない だから逆に でも私の親戚の中で本当に道徳をする人もいますよと
すごくもう苦労しながらいい人生をよくかなえている人々
その人々がもう寝たきり
臨終なときになったら
私はまた約束してもらったことはありますよと
あなた方はちゃんと天国に行くんだぞと
ですから 私もこれからでも人生直しますから
天国に行ったならば私に言ってくださいと
言って約束して死ぬんだけど
一度も天国から来て 報告したことがないんだと
ただ お坊さんの反論は
あなた一応 天国の話 お坊さんの話
たとえインチキであろうとも 聞いたことがあるでしょうということで
天国の寿命は知ってますかと
一番 低いレベルの天国にしても
人間の100年が 1日ですよと
人間の世界の100年が 向こうで 1日ですよと
そこで天国に生まれた人が 生まれた瞬間にあなたに報告するんじゃなくて
行ったところは ちょっと周りを見て
1日 2日ね みんなの挨拶して
いや 王様にもちょっと報告しなくちゃいけないんだなと思って
あなたに報告する　あなたどこにいるんですかと
もう向こうで 3日挨拶回りしただけでも
こちら 300年経ってるんだから
そんな話で もう論争を続けたんだけど
それで王様が最終的にいくら言ってもお坊さんがね
やっぱり私は唯物論は捨てませんと
そう言ったところで お坊さんが決定的な例えを言うんですよ
私に もう一つエピソードを思い浮かべますよと
このエピソードはどういうことかというと
あるものすごく貧しい村があって
その村の若者二人がね
やっぱり外へ出て稼ぎましょうと
一財産作って 楽になりましょうと
二人が外へ出るんだけど
外へ出たら町を離れていくと
途中でこの 日本語で何と言いますかね
人の便とかね それは外でやっちゃうと硬くなるんですよ
硬くなるし 臭くもないんです
それはすごくいい肥料なんです
あの便所のカスというものはね
干したならばね で それの山が見つかるんだと
そうすると この二人は自分たちのはもう 1円も 1文もない状態だからね
やっぱりこれ我々二人が袋に入れて持って行って
誰かこの畑作っている野菜作っている人に売って
ほんのちょっと何かもらいましょうと
これも商売になるんだと
ああ そういえばそうです
二人で大きな袋を二つ作って
これ頭に乗せて行くんです
価値があるんですよ いくらか一日ぐらいの食べ物でも
それでね もらえるんだから
で行く途中で あの麻という草ありますね
そういう森に出会いますと
そうすると一人がこんなものを持って行って売っても あんまり金になりませんと
でもこの麻を我々は切って束にして売っちゃえば
もっと金になるんだよ
と言ったら 一人が あなた何言うんですかね
私はどれぐらいこれ運んで 歩いてきたと思いますかと
かなりきつかったと だからこれ何のことなく捨てろと言うんですかと
私は捨てませんよと そんな苦労は水の泡になるんだと
言ったらもう一人の友達が どうぞどうぞ言って
私は捨てますよと言って
あの袋を捨てて 麻を切って束にして運んでいくんです
途中でその生の麻ではなくて
水の中に落ちてもう腐ってる麻見つかるんで
いわゆる麻の繊維ですね
したらまたあの人言うんで
やっぱりこの麻よりは 繊維持っていった方がもっと高く売れますよ と言っても
一人が麻を捨てて繊維の束を持っていく
一人が元の袋だけ持っていく
苦労して持っていったんだから捨てません
苦労は水の泡になるんですから
それでどんどん進むんで
これストーリーだからね
次に綿に出会う 次に糸に出会う 綿の
次にもう布に出会う
次に絹に出会う
でも一人は絹の束を持っていて
一人は元のものを持っていく
で さらに行ったら 銀に出会う
金にも出会う 一人が銀に出会ったところ
全部捨てて もう布 布ではなくて絹を捨てて
もう金銀を持っていくんですね
それで金に出会ったところで
あれも捨てて金を持っていくんですね
一人が元のものを 苦労は水の泡にしたくないんだからね 持っていくんです
それで最後に七宝に 宝山にぶつかるんですね
七宝が入っている それで一人がその 7つの宝物
いっぱいある宝石 種類ですけどね
それはもっと軽いんだから
それは 袋に入れて持っていくんです
もう村に帰る で
村に帰る 村に帰る途中で雨が降るんです
雨が降って あの頭の上にあったものはどんどん 水がついちゃって
溶けて 体中 もう指先まで汚物が流れていくんだと
それで村人が誰のことを褒めるんでしょうか
誰が幸せになるんですかと
村人の立場から見れば
そのようにあなたも
いくら私が反論しても
自分の古い考え方は捨てませんと
ですから どうぞご自由に
自分の考え方で有名になってください と言ったんです
そうしたら王様は そんなことはないんだと
私はあなたの最初の質問を聞いて
答えを聞いただけでも
あなた方の智慧にはもうびっくりしたんだと
ただあなたは体だけですよと
いろいろ例を出して 私は今日からちゃんとした因果法則を理解する
理解しますと これから仏教徒にもなりますと
ですから ちゃんと私を信用してくださいと
王様が一応 仏教徒になって
ストーリーと経典が終わりますけどね
だから仏教は批判するのは もう一人の
元のものを運んだ人の話なんですよ
だから 仏教は変化に反対なわけじゃないし
古臭いものでもないんです
科学反対ってわけでもないんです
真理を語っているんだから
仏教は怖くないんです
どんなに科学が発展しても
どんなに生物学 医学がいくら発展しても
DNA の研究はいくら発達しても勝手にしてと
こちらは変わりませんと
こちらの方がもっと先に行ってるんだから
ですから 皆様も知っている通りに
科学発展というのはみんな命かけてやったでしょう
地球は丸いと言ったことで 命がなくなっちゃったんだから
宗教というのはそれぐらいこの 古いものを
守りたがっているんです
だから 人間の精神の頑固さっていうのは
この宗教の世界でよく見えるんですね
だから この変化に反対なのは宗教なんです
ブッダの教えではありません
それで この宗教があってもなくても
人間はどこかで宗教的なんですよ
時々日本のテレビなんかで
この若者の話なんかを聞いていると
もう何か物事うまくいった場合は まるっきり宗教と関係ない
全くのもう それでもやっぱり私は神様がいると思ってますよと
なんでかというと やっぱりこういうことをしたらうまくいきましたと
結局 同じ馬鹿者でしょうね
私もやっぱり宗教も全部 片っ端から否定しているんだから
なかなかいい現代人
若い者ではないかと思ったところで あんなことを言っちゃうと
もう私は 同じ ということになっちゃうんですね
だから宗教がなくても
何かに頼って もう何かを信仰して というところが必ずあるんですね
だからそこが そのすごい心の頑固さなんですね
それで なんで人が死んじゃったら泣くんですかね
皆様 我々は人が死んでも泣きません というかもしれませんけど
それはまあ 死んでよかったというふうに思っている
早く死んでよかったと
という気持ちある場合は泣かないんですけど
やっぱり自分の親戚がね
おじい様が おばあ様が 両親が 大変ありがたいとね
愛情を持っていると 泣かずにはいられないと思いますけど
子供なんか病気になったらすぐ混乱する
あれ なんでしょうかね
それも同じことなんです
変わるのは嫌なんです
変わってほしくないんです
だから悲しみが生まれてくる
で 子供でも病気になったら
もうこれ嫌で嫌で それで落ち着きがなくなっちゃって
頭がもうパニック状態になって
まるっきり生きてる 狂ってる人間になっちゃうんですね
だから 子供には最初にするべき 研究的なこともできないし
それで病院に行っても
そちらの人々に落ち着いて治療することもできないし
これいろいろ文句を言うんだから
結局 問題は悪化する
落ち着いてその変化を認めたならば
いい結果になるんですよ
我々の落ち着きないのも
変化は嫌だと思っているからなんです
泣くのも変化が嫌だからなんです
悲しむのも変化が嫌だからです
よく見ていくと なんで悲しむの？はっきりしていますよ
何かが起きて悲しいでしょ
だから元の状態にいてほしいんですよ
例えば 恋人に振られたとしますね
それで悲しくなる だから
その人の悲しみを消すためには
振られた恋人がまたごめんなさいねとか言って
また仲直りしないと また元に戻れないと
悲しみが消えませんね
だから結局 人間っていうのは
物事は変化するのは嫌なんですよ
いつでも元に戻りたいんですよ
この元って何でしょうかね
どこにあるんですかね
戻りたい元はどこにあるんですかね
どんどん元に戻ってみたら
赤ちゃんになるんでしょうね
もっと元に戻ってみたら
もう胎児になっちゃうでしょうね
もっともっと元に戻ったならば
もう生まれてもないんでしょうに
だから何言うんですかね
お金がなくなったら悲しいと
なんで悲しい？やっぱり前はお金がいっぱいありましたと
だからそういうのを仏教では簡単に
もうバカとアホと 無知だと 愚か者だと
このありえないことを考えているんですね
退化すること　元に戻ること
で そこは一番アホなことを言うのは宗教なんです
で 我々は元に戻りたいんだけど
元に戻る位置は考えてないんです
今のコンピューターにしても
コンピューターおかしくなったら 元に戻すという機能があるんです
いわゆるおかしくなる前の
元に戻れます でもその場合は
そのコンピューターを使う人が
前もって戻る時点と時間を設定しておかないと
Windows ミレニアムでは動かないんです
ですから コンピューターはすごい元気で頑張って動いてくれる場合は
すぐその時間とその日にちを コンピューターに覚えさせておく
そうするとコンピューターが中にこのデータをね 記録しておいて
おかしくなっちゃったらその時点に戻ってくださいと言ったら
すぐ新しく作ったプログラム全部捨てて
元に戻ってまた機能してくれる
だからそれはそれでいいんですけど
現代 一般的な人々はただ単に元に戻りたいと
というところで 一応アホなんですけど
元に戻れる時点はあるんですよ
子供が病気になったならば
元気な時の過去を考えて
そちらに戻りたいんだと
ありえないんですけどね
過去に戻ることは でも一応 しょうがないってぐらいは言えますね
でも宗教はそうじゃないんですよ
人間には本来の姿があるんだと　生命には
だから私のこの宗教を修行すると
その人間が元の状態に
本来の状態に戻るんだよと
あれはどんな状態でしょうかね
だから皆様方 そういう話聞くとね
あの禅テキストでは もうなんとかすごい特別な発音でするんだから
未生以前(みしょういぜん)なんとかというふうに 読み方漢字もわかりません
難しい漢字で まあ そんな言葉があるんですね
一般現代語で言えば 本来という言葉ぐらいですからね
悟りって何？なんぞやと言ったら
それは人の本来の状態だと
あれ 何なのかね 本来の状態っていうのは
だから ただもう好き勝手に
お祈り文句みたいな言葉使ってるだけで わかってないと思いますけど
元に戻るってありえないんです
赤ちゃんに戻って 胎児に戻って
もっと元に戻ると　あり得るのは先へ行くことだけなんですよ
先へ行く それしかないんです
もう過去を忘れてしまえと
それ ブッダの堂々たる言葉なんですよ
いろんなところで聞こうってありますよ
過去は もう気にしないと
過去に囚われないんだと
過去は悩まないんだと
もう終わったんだからもういいでしょう　忘れちゃいます
で 仏教はもう将来に対しても悩みませんけど
一般の方々は ちょっと先のことを考えても
これはもうしょうがないんですよ
私はいいとは言わないんで
しょうがないという言葉をわざと使ってます
ちょっと将来のこと心配だわとかね
ちょっと体のことはね
ちょっと心配そうとかね
いうのは 私はしょうがないと思います
それで構いませんとは言いたくないんです
なぜならば 仏教はもっと厳密に
将来も気にせんでもいいやと
どうせ変わるんだから
放っておけばそのように変わるんだからね
それで私の 2番目のポイントで
そんなに変わる必要はあるかというところで
そんな苦労して変わらなくても 物事は変わるんですよ
変わらないものは何一つもないんです
ですから 仏教はいうのは 放っておけと
放っておいて その場 その場の条件に 正しく適応する
寒いんだったらもう 1枚を着ると
あと暑くなったらその 1枚を脱ぐと
そうやってきちんと対応する
でもその対応もその場 その場で
ずっと持ち運ぶ必要はありませんと
ですから 本当はすべてのものは 瞬間 瞬間 変わる
変わらないものはないんです
ですから 我々にはいつでも 怠ける暇がないんです
ふざける暇がないんです
今日はもう二度と出てこないんですよ
だから今日 今の時間でも二度と出てこない
ですから その時間を大事に 真剣に 有効に使う
たとえ皆様の腹が立っても
この話は ちゃんと聞いた方が得をするんです
覚えた方が得をするんです
たとえ全く反対意見かもしれません
それでも得になりますよ
こんな変な話 もうまるっきりインチキな話
なんとか坊主は言いましたよと
それぐらいでも 知識に加算されますからね
認めても認めなくても
ですから その時間でくだらんことを いろんなことを考えて
家のことやら夜のご飯を食べようかとかね
息子は今 何やってるんでしょうかとかね
そんなことを考えちゃうのは
それがもう愚か者の生き方ですよと
時間の大事さがわかってないんだよと
時間っていうのは戻らないんだよと
で 私は皆様の寿命の 大事な時間を取っちゃったんだから
もう二時半ぐらいからし始めたんだけど
そろそろ四時になります
そうすると何時間でしたっけね
計算が下手だから
ですから 皆様の寿命からね
一時間半 私はもう取っているんですよ
もう戻りません もう年取っているんです
ですから その時間を無駄にしちゃうと
これはもうどうにもならん
もう取り返しつかない大変な損なんです
だから人間には 時間というものはずーっと流れています
それでお釈迦様の お祈り文句より綺麗な言葉があります
これ昔も書きましたからね
かやの木会館で 私の悪いことでもほとんど覚えてるんです
[Accenti kālā tarayanti rattiyo,]
[Vayoguṇā anupubbaṃ jahanti;]
[Etaṃ bhayaṃ maraṇe pekkhamāno,]
[Lokāmisaṃ pajahe santipekkho.] なんか長すぎみたい
読み方はアッチェンティ カーラー タラヤンティ ラッティヨー
ワヨグナー アヌプッバン ジャハンティ
エータン バヤン マラネー ペッカマーノー
ローカーミサン パジャヘー サンティペコー
それあの綺麗な節で 覚えさせるために書いているものなんです
下は読めないね　別に覚えなくたって
[Accenti kālā tarayanti rattiyo, Vayoguṇā anupubbaṃ jahanti;
Etaṃ bhayaṃ maraṇe pekkhamāno, Lokāmisaṃ pajahe santipekkho.]
アッチェンティ カーラー タラヤンティ ラッティヨー
ワヨグナー アヌプッバン ジャハンティ
エータン バヤン マラネー ペッカマーノー
ローカーミサン パジャヘー サンティペコー
アッチェンティ カーラーっていうのは
時間はもう過ぎ去る 時間はもうなんて言いますか
タイムイズパーシング (Time is passing.)
日本語でどう言えばいいんですか
ん？過ぎていく 時間は過ぎていく
タラヤンティ ラッティヨー
タラヤンティっていうのは同じ
ラッティヨーっていうのは夜ですね
夜がもうどんどん過ぎていく
だから夜明けになると もう時間 経っているんですよ
また朝になると もう時間が流れてるんですね
時間はずっと もう過ぎ去っていくんだよと
それだけじゃない ワヨグナー アヌプッバン ジャハンティ
時間は過ぎ去ると我々のワヨ
ワヨっていうのは寿命
グナーっていうのは体の健康やら体力やらね
能力とかそういうもの
寿命と我々が持っている体力
能力などなどもアヌプッバン ジャハンティ
徐々に消えていくと
夜明けになると もう徐々に消えている
また次の夜明けで また消えていると
だからもう そんなにふざけて生きていられますかね
エータン バヤン マラネー ペッカマーノー
最終的には死んでしまいますね
だから死にますよと エータン バヤン
この怖いこと マラネー 死ぬことについて
こんな落ち着いていられないこと
これ怖いことなの 考えてみれば
だって今 若いんだけど
もう時間過ぎ去っていくんだから
若さが消えていくんですよ
今 元気なんです それ消えていくんですよ
あまり面白い話じゃないんでしょうと
それがエータン バヤン マラネー ペッカマーノー
その死に対するその脅威を観察して
ローカーミサン パジャヘー サンティペコー
世の中に対する執着を捨てて 落ち着きなさいと
サンティペコーっていうのは この平安を望む人が
ローカーミサン
世の中に対する 世の中のいろんな物事ですね 対する執着
パジャヘー 捨ててください
これあの 歌としてすごい綺麗ですよ
我々は自分の国だったら よく説法なんかにも使います
もう一つバージョンありますけど
これはもっと難しいバージョンで
4行目は変わります 簡単なバージョンでは
今日のテーマにそんなに厳密に関係ということないんだけど
一応 時間というのは瞬間 瞬間消えていく
だから時間という 今の瞬間を大事にしないと
その人ほど愚か者がいないんです
物事には後回しはできないんです
逆戻りもできません ですから
今 精一杯明るく生きると
そうすると この変わるということに 引っかからなくてもいいんですよ
このローカーミサン 世の中に対する執着
捨てなさい どういうことかというと
世の中の物に執着するということは
変化の反対派なんですよ
変わることの反対派なんですよ
お金に執着する人が お金消えることは嫌でしょう
自分の体に執着する人が 体が年取ることは嫌でしょう
だからみんな執着しすぎ
だから若者も古くさいんですよ
ダサいんですよ 私から見れば
決して流行に乗ってるわけじゃないんです
私はあんまり面白いこと喋ってみたって
あんまりにもアホらしくて
なんか新しいもの 刺激的なもの
何もないんです なぜかというと
あまりにも執着しすぎ
若者であっても 自分の体に
自分の持っているものに
遊びに執着しすぎ だから変化反対派なんですよ
だから変化に反対したら
そちらにあるのは 限りのない苦しみ
それは親が死んだら悲しいでしょう
子供が死んじゃったら悲しいでしょう
その例で考えてください
子供が先に死んじゃったら
それは悲しい なぜならば自分が変化反対派なんです
でも 変化反対派っていうこと自体ほど
この世の中で無知な考え方がありません
なぜならば 宇宙も全て もう瞬間も止まることなく 変わっていくんだから
だから私が言うのは 変わることが存在であって
永遠不滅の存在あるわけじゃないんです
永遠不滅っていうのは
愚か者の人間が 論理わからないんだから
理屈わからないんだから
正しい理屈をね わからないんだから言ってる変な考え方なんです
何の根拠もないんです
永遠不滅という言葉には
存在は無常なんです 無常が存在なんです
宇宙があるんだっていうことは
宇宙がずっと変化しているということなんです
でないと成り立たないんです
私が生きているんだということが
私が変わっているんだということなんです
でなきゃ生きてないんですよ
生きているんだからご飯食べるでしょう
生きているんだからお腹が空くでしょう
生きているんだから疲れるでしょう
だから生きてるんだってことが
私が変化しているんだ
変わっていくんだっていうことなんですよ
これ 単純な論理でわかりますよ
それなのに私が変わっても魂が変わりませんと
よく言うこと
この変わらない魂はどこにあるんでしょうか？とお釈迦様は聞きたいんですね
だから何？だからお釈迦様はこうおっしゃるんですよ
ほんのわずかな ほんのわずかなものでも
この存在において変わらないものっていうのはあるんだったら
私がこの説法なんかしませんよと
心清らかにしなさいと言いませんよと
この全存在の中で ほんのわずかなものでも無常でないものがあるならば
私は解脱の道は語りませんと
それぐらいはっきりとおっしゃっているんです
すべては無常である
何の実体もないんだよと
ですから 仏教徒になるということが
変化は認める派になることなんですよ
だから変化を認めたくない
すごい頑固でいることが 仏教の世界とは反対のなんですね
でも誰が苦しみかというと
その人々が苦しむ 何があってもどうせ起こるものだからね
そんなに気にする必要ないんですよ
何が起きても どうせこの中で起こるものが起こるんですよ
起こるべきでないものは起こるわけじゃないんです
人間に翼が生えてきたとか
角が出てきたとか 尻尾が出てきたとか
そんなことはありえないでしょうに
それだったらもう驚いてもいいんですけど
泣いてもいいんだけど
でも人間が病気になるとかね
年を取ると 車の運転間違って事故を起こしちゃうとかね
それぐらいのことでしょうに
そんなものはもうどうしてもあり得ることだから
避けられないことだから
だから楽になりたければ変化を認めること
で わざと強引に変化させようとすることは
そこのポイント ちょっと休憩取ってから喋りましょう
皆さんは大変疲れていらっしゃる
それで若い世代とかね
みんなこの いろんなものを変えようとしていますね
それについて で それも変えるのはいいんですけど
そんなに驚くほどのことじゃないんですよ
我々の物事を変えよう
新しい流行を作ろうという
その衝動が 頑固さから出てくるんです
結局はもう変えたくないという
そこから出てくるものなんですね
だから大したことじゃないんです
だからすぐもう変えても
すぐもう半年間でもう新しいものにまた変えてしまっちゃう
それは一つよく見えることで
だから変えることだけ考えれば
もう何でも変えられますからね
もう一つ 心の中で すごくこの
もう変えたくないという
この嫌な気持ちが出てくるんですよ
その気持ちにも反応して
もう状況を変えてしまう
それからつまらなくなりますね
例えば同じ色の服着ていると
同じ髪のスタイルだったら つまらなくなっちゃうんですね
なんでつまらなくなるんでしょうかね
それは無常だからなんです
それでもっと面白くなろうと
もう変えるだけで それでもそれまたつまらなくなっちゃうんです
それでまた変えてしまうと
だからそういう 変えていくことで 全然終わりがない
でも変えると言っても
もうそれほど変えることできないんですよ
だからある時期はかかとまでスカートは長いと
ある時期は膝のところになってくるんだと
ある時期は膝の上までいくんだと
お尻もちょっと見えるところまで短くなるんだと
またいきなりかかとまでくるんだと
またお尻まで上がる そればっかりなんですよ
いくらなんでもこの腰に巻くことだからね
それ以上何もできんでしょうに
だからそんな苦労して
だからみんな苦労してるんです
変えたいんだけど 変える選択肢はそれほどないんです
いくつしかないんです
新しい食べ物を食べたいという気持ちがあるんだけど
結局 食べるものは毎日 同じものなんです
そんな今日は鶏 食べたんだから
明日ゴキブリ食べましょうとなりますかね
結局は今日はもう 何と言いますか
もう油で揚げてなんとかして食べたんだと
次はもうオーブンでなんとか焼いて食べましょうとかね
次はカレーにして食べると
同じ鶏なんですけど それで変わってると思ってるんです
結局 食べてるのは同じものなんですけど
ご飯にして食べましょうと おかゆにして食べましょうと
チャーハンにして食べましょうと
おにぎりにして食べましょうと
だから面白いこと ああ
これが美味しい 同じご飯なんですけど
私にとっては全く同じで
別にどうってことないんですけど
そこであの店のチャーハンがすごくない
いえ この店のチャーハンがすごい
どんな店に行ってみたって同じなんですけど
だからそこで変わるんだ 変わるんだと
チャーハン作る時は 椎茸でも刻んで入れたら
これすごい大発明で 料理研究家なんです
椎茸の代わりにワカメでも入れたら
あまり チャーハンにワカメ入れたことは 見たことないでしょう
ワカメでも刻んできたら
あれすごい違う 変わったチャーハンでしたねとかね
そんなもんですよ もう変えたって
もう だからもう変えたいんだけど
それほど選択肢がないんです
選択肢がないんですよ
だからそんなものに そんなにこのとらわれる必要もないし
でも自由な心を持っていけば
人がびっくりするほど変化は いくらでも考えられます
ある人が私のところに来て ご飯食べてないんですね
で 私は料理は作りませんだけど
なんか訳があって
前の日に豆腐買ってあったんですね
私は日本食はできませんから 私は人に作ってあげる場合はカレー作ってあげる
自分にはそれには自信がありますからね
下手な料理作って食べさせて人のお腹壊すよりは
相手には口に合わなくても まともな料理作って食べさせたいんです
ですから この私はどこかに行くといったら
そちらの人々は本を買ってきて 勉強してカレー作ってくれるんですね
あれはちょっとした まあありがたい
ありがた迷惑なんですけど
自分に上手におにぎり握れるんだったら
それで私はすごい美味しく感じますけど
本人がそこら辺でプロだからね
この初心者で試しに 作る
で カレーの味よく知ってる人に食べさせちゃうとね
まあそれは置いておいて
ですから 私は一応カレー作りましょうと思ったら
カレーはいいですよね
私は豆腐しかないんだけどと
豆腐のカレーどうですかと
あなた何言うんですか？変でしょ
そんなことは そんな食べられませんと
豆腐のカレーなんかできっこはないんだと
ああそう じゃあ見てみろと言って
日本の風なカレーではなくて
我々の伝統的なカレーの作り方で
自分の国では豆腐はありません
一種類あります すごい硬い
この向こうは暑い国だからね
だからこの ものすごく硬く干した豆腐はあります
それもあの高野豆腐とは違います
すごい硬い もう食べられたもんじゃないんです
ですから もう でも私は作ったんです
作って 本人も最初から嫌な顔をして食べ始めました
どうですか？なかなかうまくいくんですねとかね
不思議ですよと こんなにもよくうまくいくますよと
だからもう大胆な思考でやれば
何のことなくできます
でもソフトクリームのカレーはできません
だから私 それ頼んだっても
ソフトクリームのカレー作ってくださいって
でもそれはちょっとできません
カレーに入れてあげることはできますけど
ですから 思考を自由にしておけば
もういつでも面白いことはできるんですよ
だから 人々の新しいもの
新しい流行を作ると言っても
そんな仏教徒が驚くほど 困るほどのものじゃないんです
すごい単純なことなんで
だから心を自由にしていけば
仏教徒であるならば 決して流行に遅れません
遅れるどころか もう一歩先にいることもできます
で 昔 結構若者とかのもう
付き合うことをいっぱいやりましたからね
みんな流行に乗ってるんだけど
私はあんまりダサいやと
これ古臭いやと
あなたこういう風に変えたらどうですかと 色々デザインとか言うんですよ
言っても　そんなことやったらダメ
なんでダメですか
いや これは決まりですから
このスタイルは決まりですから
だからなんで決まりと流行っていうのは 嚙み合わない言葉でしょう
嚙み合わない 昔 自分の国の若者たちが
男たちが髪の毛を伸ばすということを 首のところまで伸ばすこと
長さがはっきり決まってるんです
そこで格好良かろうが悪かろうか
もう流行に乗ってる人々は 首のそこら辺まで髪を伸ばしてるんですね
それからみんな男たちがそんな感じだから
もうあんまり面白くないんですね
私はあれもそれはやめたらどうですかとね
髪の毛は周り あんたもうものすごく大きいんだからね
髪の毛ありすぎて そこら辺はちょっと切って
これを一つ結んでおけばいいんですか？と
で 怒られたんです そんなことはもう決まりじゃないんだと
あなたわからないんだと
今の流行はと あ そうと
でも後でいくらでも見たんですよ
男の人は髪の毛を何かバンドで結んでいるのは
随分最近ですけどね
私が言ったのは 30年前
ですから もう思考をちょっとね
そうすると その私の話を聞いたならばね
その男の子だけでも
みんなの間で全く別に 変わって見えるでしょうに
だから変わりたいんだけど
変わって見えてほしくないという
この馬鹿らしさが
何でしょうかね 変わり者っていうのは批判の言葉でしょうに
言って 流行に乗っているんだと
だから流行に乗りたければ変わり者でいいんですよ
でも変わり者は嫌で でも流行にも乗っていたいんだと
乗り遅れたくないと
そういうアホな人の話は 気にする必要ないんです
落ち着けばいいんです
どうせ物事は変わるんです
どうせ変わるんです 頑張っても頑張らなくても
知識も変わる 全ての流行も変わる
科学もなんだかんだ変わる
変わるもんだなと思っておけば
気楽に生きていられます
そこでこのもう一つ変わり方がありまして
新しい食べ物を 新しい薬と 調べては
飛んで行って食べる 飛んで行って買う ということはあるでしょ
みんなもう新しい変わり者だと思ってますけどね
今の店に売ってる豆腐は食べませんと
これはどこかで なんとかの方法で作っている豆腐しか私は食べませんと
私はもうどこかのある地方で
こういう農業の方法で作っているご飯しか食べませんよとかね
そうやって 普通の人と違っているものをやっているような感じで
食べ物と薬と栄養剤とかね
そういうものに飛ぶ人々がいますけど
あれは変わり者でもなんでもないんです
とにかく自分の健康はそのまま維持したいんだと
いわゆる元に戻りたいという頑固のなんです
だから私は毎日食べるものしか食べませんよという
たとえ体に悪いと言っても
新しいものを食べませんという人に
我々は頑固なと言うでしょ
逆に新しいものばっかり食べる人も
それが健康に それが健康に という話でやっているんだから
もう頑固者には何の変わりもないんですね
どちらでも人間というのは頑固者なんですよ
だから変わりたくないという気持ちで
どうせ変わるのに 苦労しているんです
だから これはザルで水を運ぶことと同じなんですよ
いくら苦労しても意味がないんですよ
もう逆らえないんです
だから全てのものは変化するんだから
それを理解して落ち着けば
それで流行に乗っているんです
それでこの 強引に物事変わってもいいんですけど
いろんなものをね でも人間がこの怒りと欲と無知はね
それが頑固の原因だからね
怒りと欲 無知を正当化する変わるものが あまり良くないんですよ
できるだけ欲が少なくなる 変わる方に
世界が変わる　経済システムも変わる
困らなくても 執着しなくても 欲張らなくても
生きていられるように変わる ということだったらいいんでしょう
世界は怒らない世界に変えればどうですかね
一向にそういう変わり方はないでしょう
みんなとにかく差別感で国と国が争う
平気で嘘を言う 例えば中国をいじめたいんだから
平気で もうインチキはいいところ
例えば自分たちには国の領域の中にまで入って
スパイ活動する権利があるんだと
中国には威嚇する権利はないんだと
どんな理屈ですかね それが
お互いに話し合ってやめればいいでしょうに
いろんな国々に迷惑かけることが
ソ連がアフガニスタンに侵攻していたからといって
日本もオリンピックも参加しなかったでしょう
あれ どんな思考ですかね
言って それでアフガニスタンはタリバンが一応取ったでしょうね
ソ連の方が負けたでしょ
誰に国をあげたんですかね
ただの原始野蛮人でしょうに
仏像を壊すは 女の人の教育は禁止するは
外へ出てはいけないというは
男はみんな髭を生やしていかなきゃいけない
仕事がなくなるは 髭なかったら
そういう原始人に国を与えただけでしょうに
言って中国を侵略することでも
もうユダヤ人がパレスチナ人に爆弾を落とす
それは「いい」んです
だから屁理屈もいいところで
悪いものは誰がやっても悪い
人の権利を奪ってはいけない
だから新しい思考だったら
なんで世界を平和にしましょうかと
なんでそういう思考に来ないんですかね
人類はみんな平等だから
みんな同じ兄弟だから仲良くしましょうという
なんでそういう思考に変わらないんですかね
私の神こそ素晴らしい
あなたの神は神ではないんだと
そういうもう 想像もできない嘘を言ったりして
なんで喧嘩するんですかね
だから変わる変わるって言ったって
こんな変わり方ってなんの意味もないんですよ
欲と怒りをどんどん増やす
政府スケールで嘘を言う
20年経たないと それは嘘であることはバレないと
秘密だと　なんで国に秘密はあるんですかね
だからこの変わりたければ
仏教から言えるのは やっぱり
むさぼり 怒りをなくす生き方をしましょうと
それが本当の変わり方ですよと
だって 我々はむさぼりと怒りと無知の塊でしょう
だから頑固でしょう
だから柔軟性がないでしょう
敵を愛することはできないんですよ
嫌な人にも どうか幸せでありますようにと 祝福することはできないでしょう
自分に邪魔している人に対しても
どうか気をつけてくださいと
人々が心配してあげることできますか？
自分の足を引っ張ろうとしている人に対しても
それが本物の変わりなんですよ
本当の変わり者なんですよ
敵にもご飯作ってあげる
たとえ敵であろうとも
病気になったら真剣に看病してあげる
我が子のように慈しみで見る
それが本当の変わることなんですよ
だから私から言えば もう誰も変わってないんです
ただ頑固者で だから この現代世界で見られる変わるということが
仏教から見れば なんて面白くない
なんとも面白くない 変わるんだったら大胆に変わってほしい
人間にできないほどのことに変わってほしい
みんな驚くほどに変わってほしい
なんて人ですかと そこまであなた変わりますかと
人をびっくりさせるほどに変わってほしい
それをお釈迦様がやってみせたんです
いまだにその智慧にはみんなびっくりするしか
もう理解できないほど難しいんです
難しくはないんだけど ブッダの教えは
我々は頑固だから理解できないだけで
それが本当の変わることなんですよ
ワンパターンで生きていることじゃないんだ
我々はずっとこの動物と同じく
この感情で生かされているだけ
生きているわけじゃないんです
欲が出てきて 何か動けと言ったら動く
欲の感情が出てきて あれ取れ
これ取れ あれ儲かる これしなさい
あの服を買いなさい 言っちゃうと
奴隷みたいに 欲の奴隷で言うことをやってあげる
それで私は結構 流行に乗ってるんだよと　何言うんですかね
ただの奴隷でしょうに
それで怒りがあるでしょうに
怒りが出てきたら もう何でもすると
それで自分が変わり者だと言われるので
変わり者でもなんでもないんで
ただ怒りの奴隷なんです
ですから ずっと生命っていうのは動物も同じく
貪瞋痴の衝動で生かされているんですよ
この生かされてという言葉というのは
結局 いい言葉じゃないんですよ
すごいもう品のない言葉なんです
生かされててありがたいと　何がありがたいんですか？
アホじゃないんですか？生きていなさいと
生かされているということは
言葉を変えれば 飼われているという意味でしょうに
日本文化では すごいありがたい言葉なんですけど
生かされているんじゃなくて
生きてみなさいよと 自分で
これはブッダの教えなんです
ですから 我々は結局 生かされ飼われているだけ
貪瞋痴に飼われている
偉い人に飼われてるんだったら いいんですけど
飼われてるのは 貪瞋痴に飼われているんですよ
だから 生きることは苦労が多いだけなんです
ですから お釈迦様はこういう言葉で
[Nihīyati puriso nihīnasevī.]
ニヒーヤティプリソ ニヒーナ・セーヴィ
プリソ 人が
ニヒーナ・セーヴィ 卑しい人と付き合う
卑しいというのは まあね
すごい品のない
ものと付き合うと ニヒーナ・セーヴィ
ニヒーナというのは卑しいという意味なんですね
ものすごく 優れているという言葉の反対ですね
そういう卑しいのものと付き合うと
ニヒーヤティ 卑しくなっちゃいますよと
堕落するんだよ
だから 貪瞋痴に飼われていることをありがたがっても
結局 堕落するだけなんです
ですから この これまた途中で二行ありますけど それ
抜かして四行目書きます
[tasmā attano uttariṃ bhajetha]
これはすごい このモットーとしてもいい言葉ですよ
で あのタスマっていうのは ですからという意味で
アッタノ ウッタリン 自分より優れている　ものでも人でもいいんです
自分より優れている人と バジェータァ(bhajetha)
人と付き合いなさい なぜかというと
卑しいものと付き合うと 堕落するんだから
自分より優れているものと 付き合いなさい
それは人でもいいし 性格でもいいんですよ
例えば 自分には怒りがあると 怒りが卑しいものでしょう
怒りがすごい尊いわけじゃないでしょう
憎しみ 嫉妬 怒り それは心にあるんだから
それは 心で養うと卑しい人になってしまうんですから
その代わりに 慈しみという優れているものと付き合う
それは性格の場合
人の場合でも 自分より いつでも
優れている人々と 付き合ってみてくださいと
どんどん変わってきますよ
その場合はいい方向へ
もうたくさんありますからね
もう今日私は用意したものからはね
一行 二行しか使ってないんです
全部パーリって もうパーリ経典から持ってきたんだけど
それからこの 物事を変わる勇気とかね
まあ変わりたくないということは
やっぱり怠けであってね
それはもう 良くないし
やっぱり変わる勇気が必要なんですよ
我々 勇気っていうのは
我々 本来 頑固だから 本来 ものすごく変わりたくないという
妄想概念にも縛りつけられているんだから
だからきつく ものすごい硬い柱に
もう鎖で体中を巻かれているんですね
動かないんです 変わるということは
指をそっと動くぐらいのことだからね
ですから 我々の心は貪瞋痴そのもので
それに飼われている だから
いくら我々変わった変わったと思っても
貪瞋痴が増えるだけで
それで苦しみが 形変わって増えてるだけで
幸せにはならないんですね
ですから 変わりたければ必要なのは
うんと どこかにありました
この心の状態はこういうお釈迦様
これお釈迦様の専門用語なんですけど
2つの言葉 アーランバ・ダートゥ
ニッカマ・ダートゥ
パラッカマ・ダートゥ という 3つなんですね
これはあの ある特別な
この心にあるエネルギーなんですね
これどういうことかというと
やっぱり何かやりたいという気持ちがあっても
どうも腰が上がらないんですね
やる気にはならないんですね
その あ こういうこういうこと
じゃあやりましょうかと言って
この立ち上がる機能なんですよ
行動に移る この心の働きなんですね
ですから このダートゥというのは
この根拠 エレメント 基本的なパワーなんですね
アーランバっていうのはスタートする
開始するという意味 何でもこのスタートする
開始する この精神的なパワーを育ててほしいと
それ育てる方法は何でしょうかって聞いて
方法ないんです ただやるしかないんです
で ニッカマっていうのは
やって途中でやめるんではなくて
続けると 途中ででも まあ嫌だ
やめたということになるんですね
気持ちが弱くなるんですね
やっぱりいいこと始めたら やっぱりやり続けてみます
それがね パラッカマっていうのは
それを全部まとめてすごい勇気ということ
勇気には 仏教では違う言葉なんですけど
パラッカマっていうのは 並ならぬ勇気っていう意味なんですね
普通の勇気には ヴィリヤ(viriya)と言うんですよ　精進
パラッカマという場合は
もうこの並の精進 努力ではないんです
かなり 頑張らないと
それはお釈迦様は何に思ってますか？
心にある この怠け 変わりたくない気持ち
この心の頑固さ それを破るために この3つ必要ですよ
だから口を開けて 口に餌が落ちるまで待っていても 来ないっていう
だから頼る宗教は そういう頼る世界はね
なんとか し賜えとね
で 待っていると言っても
やはり自分でやらないと
本当かどうかわかりませんけど
この我々の国のある普通の一般的な言葉遣いですけど
なんとかの名前の鳥なんですけど
水は飲まないんだ 飲めないんだと
くちばしはもうちょっと平らみたいなものなんですね
それで水が飲みたいんだ
飲みたい時はもう飲めないんだから
とにかく雨が降るまで 待たなくちゃあかんと
そこでいつでも口を開けてるんだと
なんで口を開けてるんだというと
この雨が降って 水でも落ちてくれれば飲めるのにということだと
だから それで我々にこの子供の頃ね
かなり親にそんな話をしてね
お前らなんで怠けるんですか ということの言われたことなんですけど
私は本当にその鳥はそんな馬鹿かとわからないんだけど
水が必要だったらすぐ飲まなきゃね
おそらく昔の人々がその鳥なんか見たら
その鳥が常に 口を開けてる習慣があったかもしれません
それに仏教的な言葉を入れちゃって
仏教はもう神に祈る それが反対だからね
あの鳥もなんか もう空から落ちてくるまで待ってるんだよという
もう解釈したでしょうと思います
だから それは仏教はもう我々
私にも言われたんだからね
もう怠けると ...なんとか鳥みたいにね
待ってるんじゃないよと
自分で頑張る 頑張って
自分でやりたいことは自分でやるんだよと
ですから この変わる勇気を与え賜え ではなくて
変わる勇気は自分で作るんです
自分で変わるんです それしか方法はないと
そこで物事が変わるために 勇気が出てくるもう一つの方法っていうのは
すべてはどうせ変わります
心配する必要はないんです 何にも
だからすべてのものは変わるんだから
何か変わったんだから大変だ 大変だという
その気持ちは要りません
ですから 諦めるという 2番目の漢字ありますね
このタイトルに 諦めるという意味は 理解するって意味なんです
諦めるっていうことは
本当に理解する 何を理解するかというと
すべては変わると 無常であると
ですから このカタカナで諦めと書いたのは
これを腰抜けの生き方
何にも勇気なし もう頑張れないんだと
もうダメだと その諦めではなくて
もう物事は変わるんだよということを 理解しておきなさいと
そうすると何も怖いものはなくなるんです
勇気が出てくるんです
で 時間はもう あまりにも残酷的に過ぎ去ったんだから
もうそこら辺で話を締めさせていただきます
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]